a shortage of workers continues to
impact a number of different fields from
restaurants to hospitals so tonight
we're going to show you another area
being stretched really thin and that's
home health staff as victoria saha shows
us many are being left helpless for days
without enough people to serve them
yeah for many of us we can't even
imagine relying on someone else for our
day-to-day needs but for some they have
absolutely no choice but to pay for at
home health aid and when that help
doesn't come they're left stranded
the caregiver didn't show up teresa
caruso is bedridden because of an
extremely rare condition causing her to
grow another skeleton basically encasing
me in a statue of bone leaving her to be
immobilized and needing constant
assistance i need to wear diapers 24
hours a day
so i need help changing
my diaper
i can't cook for myself but no one from
a home aid agency has been able to help
her since december because of the worker
shortage leaving her to endure
unimaginable situations i've been left
in my diaper for at least 24 hours up to
two days according to becky torres the
owner of bright star care the gap is
being fueled by homemade agencies
competing with hospitals nursing homes
and the omercron surge we turn down
business all the time now at her agency
there are at least 60 aids short we make
calls to our families and we say please
understand we'll do our best doing her
best to constantly recruit i can always
train somebody on the skills but i can't
train you on having the heart to do it
as for caruso she's relying on the help
from her mom until a new aide comes in
and despite her difficulties she still
manages to keep a smile on i'm just full
of hope and joy and love and i just give
it away
cruiser says her new aid will start
february 14th but even then it's just
going to be for a couple of hours
whereas pre-pandemic she would have an
aid for a full eight hours if you are
interested in becoming an at-home aide
brightstar says they will train you but
you need to have at least one year of
experience that link will be up on our
website at eightnewsnow.com reporting
from the newsroom tonight victoria saha
live local now